everyone welcome back let's solve
another problem today
longest increasing subsequence and this
is another tricky dynamic programming
problem
and i'm going to show you how to go from
the recursive solution
to the dynamic programming solution so
we're given
an array of numbers and we just want to
return the length of the longest
increasing subsequence
and if you don't know what a subsequence
is it's basically
like let's say this is our input array
we're basically taking a
subarray but that subarray does not have
to be
contiguous so like we have from here so
uh subsequence is three six two seven
basically we took this subarray
and we removed one two from it and we
removed a one from it and now it's three
six two seven but you notice about this
subsequence
it's not an increasing order right we
have six and then we have two that's not
increasing order so this is not a
increasing subsequence so in this
example we're given
about nine elements and we want the
longest increasing subsequence
which we see is this and so how did we
get that subsequence well you go from 2
all the way to 101 but you notice
that unfortunately this is not an
increasing
order we have a 5 and then we get a 3
right after so we actually have two
choices
if we remove the three we have an
increasing
subsequence if we remove the five we
also have an increasing subsequence but
we just care about the length
which in this case is four so we return
four
so the first idea you might have is
brute force
using depth first search so let's say
that
this is our input array so we have six
elements for if we wanna know the brute
force meaning we want to generate
every possible subsequence we have a
choice for each value right so for the
first
0 we have a choice are we going to
include this
0 in our subsequence or are we not going
to include it in our subsequence
so in reality for each value we have
two choices now when we get to the next
value we
also have a choice are we including it
or not
so again we have two choices if we want
to generate
every possible subsequence so we do that
for every single value
and then we see that there are actually
2 to the power of
n possible subsequences where n is the
number of values
given in our input array so already you
can see the time complexity is not going
to be
great but can we take this brute force
approach and then somehow modify it
to get a better solution like n squared
so let's look at another example and
this time we're going to do depth first
search
with caching and we're going to see how
that improves our time complexity so
we have an example of four elements so
it's kind of obvious that this is our
longest increasing subsequence so the
result is going to be
three three elements but how can we do
this with an algorithm that's efficient
well let's start out with the brute
force approach
let's check all subsequences starting at
index 0 and then repeat that starting at
index
one starting at index two and starting
at index
three right so these are the indices so
we take
one decision to start at index
zero we take one decision to start at
index one
one decision to start at index two and
one decision to start at
index three so in these cases
these are going to be the subsequences
we have so far so we know index zero has
value 1
index 1 has value 2 index 2 has value
4 index 3 has value 3.
so now let's go along the first path so
index 0 so we know if we start at index
zero
we have three values that come after it
so we can try
all three of these possible decisions
so we can go along index one index
two and index three and we see that
all three are possibly valid because all
three of these values are greater than
one
so we can continue these subsequences so
we know index one has value two
index two has value four so we can add a
four
index three has value three so we can
add a
three to our subsequence that originally
was just
one so now we took index
zero and index one so for here we only
have
two indices that come after these two
values
so let's continue our decisions we see
that both
four and three are greater than the
the last value in our subsequence which
is two
so we can choose both of these decisions
so if we take index 2 then we can add a
4 to our subsequence if we take index 3
we can add a
3 to our subsequence so now let's
continue here we have
three values so far in our subsequence
and there's one
index that comes after two index three
it has a value three
so can we add a three to our subsequence
we'll get one two four and then 3
but this 3 is not greater
than the last value in our subsequence
so we technically
cannot make this decision so we cannot
continue
to increase the subsequence anymore
so we can mark this as reaching its
limit we cannot continue it anymore what
about
this one well it stopped at index three
which was over here
so are there any elements that come
after it now
no there's not any elements so this
subsequence
has also reached its limit so we cannot
increase it
anymore but so now let's focus on this
caching part
what kind of repeated work have we
eliminated well let's just
do this out of order instead of doing
these first let me show you what happens
if we try to extend the three now
we try to get another element right we
started at index
three but we know that no values come
after index three so this one cannot be
continued
but what do we know about index three
if we start at index three and we want
the longest increasing
subsequence we just get a single three
so that tells us that lis starting at
index three is one we don't need to
repeat this work
and isn't that what we just learned over
here
even though this subsequence is length
3 we are talking about starting at the 3
and we noticed we could add a 3 to it
right
this was the element that we added but
as soon as we added that three we
could not add we could not increase this
subsequence anymore right that's what
this
x tells us we were only able to add
one element if we start at index three
and that's exactly what this two told us
as well if we start at index two
we can add a four but this three that
comes after it cannot be
added we cannot include that and there
aren't any more elements to add
so as soon as we finish this and we
found this x meaning we could not go any
lower
we knew we knew that the
longest increasing subsequence starting
at index
two is also one so
therefore if we start at index two
we cannot go any lower we cannot
continue this
and we don't even have to attempt to do
that and what about
this branch so if we chose if we
started at index one we would start with
the
subsequence of two right that's what
this tells us
and so now i'm gonna repeat i'm gonna
do some more stuff right i'm gonna
choose the next indices
two and three but wait a minute do i
actually have to do that
because look over here
we started with index one and we already
did that so when we started with index
one
we saw we had two choices a two or a
three index right we could choose this
or we could choose that we saw both of
them
ended right we could not continue either
of them
so if you want the longest increasing
subsequence
that starts at index 1 over here
no matter what you choose the
subsequence
is gonna be length two either way right
because
if we start with a two then we can add a
four
or we can add a three but we cannot add
both of them so we can mark the longest
increasing subsequence
starting at index one to be length
two so we actually don't even have to
go down this path once we already
go down here because it's just gonna be
repeated work
and we also see for these two trees that
we have not finished yet
once we add a four the longest
increasing
subsequence at index two which is where
four is at is going to be 1 so we cannot
continue this
anymore similarly once we add a 3
we know no values come after it the
longest increasing substituent starting
at index 3 is just
1 we cannot increase this anymore so
when we finally in our depth first
search get back to the root
we're gonna see that the longest path is
one of these right either that or of
course you could
go down this direction but either way
the longest
increasing subsequence starting at index
zero
is going to be three and so when you
look
at these four right because these are
our subsequences these are the longest
subsequences starting at each index the
greatest
one is three and so therefore the result
is three but now if you actually wanna
do the dynamic
programming solution you might notice
how we're doing this recursively we're
kind of starting at the last
index right three and then working our
way
up backwards to zero so then going back
here so can we use that to do dynamic
programming
so now let me show you the dynamic
programming solution and it's actually
easier than you might think so we're
going to work we're going to start at
the last index 3 and then
work our way backward so we know this is
kind of the base case right
no values come after it so the longest
increasing subsequence we could make
from here is just going to be
length one anyway so we can say the lis
starting at index three is just one
that's the max
length now how do we get the longest
increasing subsequence
starting at index two which is
just one shifted to the left well
one possibility is just four by itself
right so that's one possibility it could
just
be one or it could be
one plus the longest increasing
subsequence starting at position three
and what this means is if we take
both of these right because lis of three
is just
one right so three by itself but we're
only
allowed to do this if the value
nums at index 2 which we know is 4
is less than nums at index
3 which we know is 3. is this
true this is not true so we are
not allowed to do this so normally we
would take the max of these two values
but we know that the condition
to take the max of this does not satisfy
so we only have one choice
one so the lis of this is going to be
one i'll put it over
here like in the corner so again we're
gonna work our way backwards so let's
get the longest increasing subsequence
one index back at index one so we're
going to do the similar
thing that we just did so we know we
could take a subsequence
two by itself right that's one choice
one is a choice length one we also have
a choice
one plus the longest increasing
subsequence starting at four
and we're allowed to do this because two
is less than four so it
is increasing the subsequence is
increasing
so another choice is one plus
lis of two and another choice is
l i s starting at index three because
two
is less than three right two is less
than three so the subsequence is in
increasing order so one plus l i s
of three now we know that this is two
and this is two so it doesn't really
matter which one we do
the lis of one is
going to be equal to two regardless
so now we want the longest increasing
subsequence starting at index zero and
we're just going to repeat what we just
did so
we could take one by itself which is
just one
or we could take one add it with the
longest increasing subsequence starting
at two
or this longest increasing substitution
starting at
at this index or this index so we know
we're going to get
1 plus 1 from here we're going to get 1
plus 1
from here and we're going to get 1 plus
2 from here and we're allowed to do all
of these because you notice
2 is greater than 1 4 is greater than 1
and 3 is greater than 1 so they're an
increase
so they are an increasing order so then
we know that the longest increasing
subsequence of this
is going to be equal to 3 which is what
we want
so this is a much better solution the
dynamic programming solution is much
better than brute force
because the time complexity is o of n
squared but why is it o of n squared
well you see we're working backwards we
start at three
and then we check every position
afterwards which is not
too bad right so then we iterate through
basically every value here
when we start at four we have to look at
every value that comes
after it there's only one value that's
good for us
so we iterate through these two values
when we start at two we have to check
these subsequences starting at these two
values
so then we have to end up iterating
through two
and every value that comes after and we
do the same
thing for one so we iterate through one
and
every value that comes after so you can
tell by looking at this
this pattern is similar to an n squared
pattern so now let's finally write the
code so we know we're going to do this
dynamic programming style so let's have
a
cache or a list it's initially going to
be set to
1 every value is going to be set to 1
it's going to be the length of the input
array that we're given
so every longest increasing subsequence
starting at every value or every index
is initially just set to one we're going
to try to find what the max is
so we want to iterate through every
index
in the range of our input array
and we want to do it in reverse order so
that's what i'm going to do in python
it if you're not familiar with python
this might look a little weird but
basically what i'm doing is starting at
the last index
and then going all the way to zero and
just like i showed in the example
we're going to start at index i like
this could be i and then we want to
iterate through
every subsequence that came after it so
i'm going to have another nested loop
for j
in range so starting at i plus 1
and then going to the end of the input
array
and before we can update lis
we want to know is the value
at i actually less than the value
at j because j comes after it if we want
this to be an
increasing subsequence this condition
has to
be true and only then are we allowed
to update the longest increasing
subsequence
at index i and we can set it to the max
of itself and or the max
of 1 plus the lis
starting at j because we know for sure
j is going to be in increasing order
with i
and literally that is it we made sure to
evaluate that it's an increasing order
we did it backwards we made sure to
cache the repeated work
what do we have left to do well we want
to return what the max is how can we do
that well
in python you can just take the max of a
list so whatever
uh the long whatever the greatest value
is in here
is going to be returned and they're
actually so this is
o of n squared and there actually is a
better solution
big o of n log n but i really
doubt your interviewer is going to
expect you to get this on your own
without a hint
if they do i would personally just walk
out of the room
but i hope this was helpful if you
enjoyed please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon